in this video i thought i'd explain how
i use bridging finance to recycle my
cash when i'm buying properties so i
don't leave my money in properties i
pull my money out effectively making my
property deals that i do no money down
deals and i've done hundreds of property
deals over the years i've also trained
thousands of people to do the same let's
say there's a hundred thousand pound
house and you want to buy it it's in
good condition most people will put down
25 000 pound deposit and then they'll
get a mortgage for the rest you don't
want to do that you want to find a
property that's run down that's filthy
that's disgusting that has the potential
to be like that nice hundred thousand
pound house but you buy it for fifty
thousand pounds
you use twenty five thousand pound of
your money to buy it and you use the
rest on bridging finance the refurb the
remaining 25 000 pounds so all in you
put 75 000 pound in but then you've
pushed the value up so it's like the 100
grand house you then get a normal
mortgage and get 75 grand and use that
75 grand to pay off the bridging and pay
yourself back and that's how you
refinance and recycle your cash